Unit testing is something we're going to
spend a lot of time in this course
looking at.
And unit testing means
looking at some
small software module at a time
and testing it in an isolated fashion.
And so this is what we were doing
with the bounded buffer example
from the last unit and
with the square root function that we
were talking about earlier in this unit.
The main thing that distinguishes
unit testing from other kinds of testing
is that we're testing a smaller
amount of software.
Often the person
performing the unit testing
is the same person
who implemented the module,
and in that case we may well
be doing white box testing.
But unit testing can also be
black box testing.
The goal of unit testing is to find
defects in the internal logic
of the software under test
as early as possible,
in order to create
more robust software modules
that we can compose later
with other modules
and end up with a system
that actually works.
Besides the size of the software
under test, the other thing that
distinguishes unit testing from other
kinds of testing is that
generally, at this level,
we have no hypothesis
about the patterns of usage
of the software under test.
In other words, we're going to try
to test the unit with inputs
from all different parts of its domain.
Remember,
the domain is the set of possible inputs
for this piece of software.
Unit testing is also a kind of testing
that enjoys a great deal of
good tool support,
and... so Python, in fact, has a number of
frameworks for unit testing.
It also has a number of frameworks
for what are called mock objects,
and what mock objects are is fake objects
that we can bolt under the software
under test that mock up the behavior
of the larger software system
in which this unit lives.
And what we'll do is,
we'll include links to some of these tools
in the supplemental material
for this course.